a
communauté.
Pascal Robidas.
- En plein après-midi, quartier
Chomedey, à Laval, hier.
Deux fillettes tentent
d'attraper deux ch voiture q von
véhicule suspect noir s'approche
à quelques mètres d'elles pour
ouvrir le feu sur un individu
L'homme atteint à la cuisse
tente de trouver r trouver r tre
sous leurs regards.
- Moi, j'étais ici en train de
prendre du soleil. J'avais mes
écouteurs. J'ai entendu
VLADIMYR VITAL, témoinmoinmoin
- Ce sont des choses qui
arrivent que... I mean, on vae t
pas bien du tout parce que
ça risque la vie du monde.
Puis, il y avait deux filles
Oh, my God!
- Laval, c'est rendu
le Far West, c'est tout.
devenu le théâtre de la violenc,
trois fusillades ont fait
un mort,
après-midi. Le service de police
dit avoir déployé des effectifs
sur le terrain pour freineri ébt
la population lavalloise.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS ROUSSELLE,
Service de police de Laval
mes enquêteurs, depuis
urs, n'ont pas
réellement dormi, si vous
me prêtez l'exprils travaillente
pour solutionner ces crimes-
- La tentative de meurtre d'hier
après-midi portes de rue. D'abo,
le véhicule du tireur suit
discrètement celui de sa cible.
Puis, lors d'un deuxième
l'individu qu'il doit
abattre. Le tireur aura à peine
que son conducteur, lui,
à enfoncé l'accélérateur
pour prendre la fuite.
- Vous savez, sur le territoire,
on a plugs de rue.
Certaines d'entre elles
ont des conflits non seuleme
entre elles à Laval, mais ont
lits avec d'autres gangs
de Montréal.à Laval
ont alimenté le débat
à l'Assemblée nationale.
GENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ministre
- La stratégie Centaure porte
ses fruits. Il y a
semaines, j'avais un briefing de
suivi avec tous les corps de
de Laval, qui me dit qu'ils sont
très, tfs sur le
terrain.
- Entre-temps, les citoyens
s'accompagne d'une flambée
nce dans lnce dans lnce dans ln.
Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, à